question de noé les poissons dorment
t-il c'est vrai qu'on peut se poser la
question parce que jamais ils ne ferment
les yeux en fait c'est parce qu'ils
n'ont pas de paupières mais apparemment
oui les poissons dorment enfin ils
dorment ils se reposent ils en ont
besoin comme tous les animaux disons
plutôt qu'ils font de bonnes siestes
tout en restant en alerte pour échapper
aux prédateurs après ils ont chacun
leurs petites habitudes les poissons
comme par exemple se repose au milieu
des coraux agir elle s'enfuit dans le
sable les requins quant à eux restent en
mouvement pour que nos continue à
circuler le long de leurs bronchique
qu'il puisse respirer car c'est branché
ne sont pas mobiles d'autres comme les
poissons perroquets enfile même leur
pyjama avant de dormir une sorte de
mucus qui masque les honneurs et les met
à l'abri des prédateurs